[Music]
out of the blue a new Jurassic world
movie has been announced which is set to
be released very soon and even has a
veteran of the franchise involved what's
more the Harry Potter remake is taking
shape and might even lead to several
Series this and much more awaits you now
in the Koch
news The Lion King returns new details
about the plot of the prequel Mufasa
have now been disclosed via X Disney's
The Lion King is probably one of the
best known and beloved animated movies
of all time Simba's Journey has thrilled
viewers for generations and made for an
unforgettable Movie experience in 2019
this was followed by the live action
remake of the same name which was able
to achieve worldwide box office takings
of over $1.6 billion in spite of mixed
reactions from critics and fans in the
course of the Remake success Disney
announced a prequel that would shed
light on the rather vague backstory
story of Simba's father Mufasa new
details about the project have now been
published via X as the Hollywood handle
announced Mufasa The Lion King tells the
story of the young Mufasa who was
separated from his parents by a flood
and subsequently rescued by a lion cub
named taka the two become friends and
grow up together like brothers as the
years go by they are faced with a group
of other Lions who threaten their
existence both Mufasa and taka have to
flee on their Journey they encounter all
kinds of dangers that put their loyalty
to each other to the test as we already
know the prequel will also deal with how
taka eventually became scar based on the
1994 book A Tale of Two Brothers whether
Mufasa The Lion King can meet fans
expectations is yet to be seen the movie
directed by Barry Jenkins is due to be
released in cinemas on December 20th
2024 we can't
wait there's a new cast member for
Daredevil born again will Wilson bethl
will be back in his role as Bullseye
Marvel's Daredevil Born Again has truly
not had an easy time in recent months
the production of the series has
repeatedly attracted public attention
due to various problems including the
rejection of the footage shot so far and
the layoff of all writers and directors
in the meantime though the project seems
to have found a new course Dario
scardapane known for The Punisher series
is now the new showrunner Justin Benson
and Aaron Morehead will direct the
remaining episodes the series is to be a
direct successor to the Netflix version
which is therefore also part of the MCU
Cannon as comic book.com is now revealed
Wilson bethl will be seen in his role as
Bullseye in at least three episodes
however Marvel has yet to confirm this
there are also increasing rumors that
Elden Hensen and Deborah Anne wolf will
also be reprising their roles as foggy
and Karen so far Charlie Cox as Matt
Murdoch Vincent de arreo as Kingpin and
John Bernthal in the role of the
Punisher have been confirmed but we can
safely expect one or two more stars to
join the
project news from Harry Potter last year
Warner Brothers announced that the story
of the famous Hogwart student would be
remade in the form of a series a number
of writers are currently pitching their
best ideas to the studio there are also
more and more rumors that several series
from the Harry Potter World could be
developed although the announcement of a
Harry Potter series remake was met with
a rather mixed reaction from fans Warner
Brothers still seems to be confident
about the project the concept behind it
is to produce a separate season for each
of the books the aim is to deal with
significantly more details of the
original book series that only played a
subordinate role in the previous movies
or did not feature at all since this
announcement The Wizarding World has
turned into a veritable playground for
authors as they are competing for the
coveted chance to adapt JK Rowling seven
books into a series a report from
deadline states that well well-known
writers such as Martha hiler Kathleen
Jordan Tom Moran and Michael Leslie have
already submitted their Creative Visions
to streaming service Max and Warner
Brothers television the group has been
tasked with creating pitches for a
series that reflects their individual
take on JK Rowling's intellectual
property it seems that the magical
journey has only just begun as the first
round of pitch meetings took place in
Los Angeles this week according to
Insider information the best ideas will
proceed to the next round in the UK
however it remains unclear how involved
JK Rowling is in the decision-making
process as deadline further reports the
choice would not necessarily have to
fall on just one author the multitude of
interesting ideas could rather lead to
several Harry Potter projects being
developed at the same time however it is
important to emphasize that the entire
process is still at an early age
representatives from Max and Warner
Brothers have so far refrained from
commenting on the matter what is certain
though is that Warner has big plans for
the the series CEO David zaslav has
already revealed that the series is to
be released over a period of 10 years
which is quite an impressive
announcement listen up dinosaur fans 3
years after the last Jurassic World
adventure another part is to follow
after all and a veteran of the franchise
is also involved Universal Pictures
produced one of the most successful
Blockbuster series of all time with the
Jurassic world Trilogy the dinosaur Saga
made over three billion dollars although
the reviews were rather mediocre to
below average the franchise still seems
to enjoy undiminished popularity it
should therefore come as no surprise
that Universal wants to maintain this
level of popularity and as now announced
a new movie 2 years after the grand
finale Jurassic world Dominion according
to the Hollywood Reporter a very special
person has been brought back for
Jurassic world 4 we are talking about
author David cat who previously co-wrote
the screenplays for for Jurassic Park
and Jurassic Park 2 the Lost World it
seems that Universal Pictures wants to
turn to the atmosphere of the older
movies it may also come as a surprise
that the new movie is due to be released
in cinemas as early as
2025 meaning that the script is as good
as finished so far no director has been
confirmed for the project there is also
no information on a possible cast
however the new Jurassic world movie is
set to introduce a new era in the
franchise possibly with a number of new
actors it is therefore rather unlikely
that the cast around Chris Pratt and
Bryce Dallas Howard will return for the
new movie though nothing can be ruled
out the Book of Eli released in 2010
expanded the apocalypse genre with an
exciting and star studded movie 14 years
later a prequel series is now being
developed according to initial
information it will be set 30 years
before the events of the movie in the
leading role is John boa as deadline
reports the star Wars actor will also be
an executive producer for the series
prequel The Book of Eli tells the story
of the lone fighter Eli who wanders
through the destroyed America of 2044
while protecting a mysterious book that
is said to have special powers the
series however will focus on the nuclear
catastrophe and the resulting collapse
of civilization currently it is not
expected that Denzel Washington will
return for the project in any form
whatsoever there's also no information
on the rest of the cast as of yet
however it is possible that we will see
a younger version of the villain carnegi
played by Gary Oldman the series The
Book of Eli is currently still up for
grabs so it remains to be seen who will
ultimately acquire the rights to the
project the 96th academy awards ceremony
is just around the corner on March 10th
the Dolby Theater in Los Angeles will
decide who will take home the
prestigious Oscars Christopher Nolan's
3-hour epic opener is the top favorite
in this year's competition the movie
starring killing and Murphy was able to
secure a total of 133 nominations
including in the categories best film
best actor and Best Director the science
fiction fairy tale poor things is close
behind with 11 nominations lead actress
Emma Stone is considered a strong
Contender for the osar for best actress
in a leading role Martin scorsis killers
of the flower moon was able to secure 10
nominations while Leonardo DiCaprio is
not among the nominees Lily Gladstone is
competing with Emma Stone for best
actress in a leading role fans of the
iconic plastic doll Barbie also have a
reason to celebrate the comedy directed
by Greta Gerwig has been nominated in
eight categories these include best film
best production design and best song
Ryan goling can also hope to win an
Oscar for best supporting actor Seline
songs drama past lives is likely to have
the best chance in the best original
screenplay category the best animated
feature category also has plenty to
offer on one side there are big hits
like Disney's Elemental Spider-Man
across the spider BST and hayo
miyazaki's the boy of the Heron and on
the other some less big movies such as
robot dreams and neona from Netflix last
but not least there is a real surprise
in the best visual effects category
alongside Ridley Scotts Napoleon the
third adventure of the Guardians of the
Galaxy and the Creator too's Mega
success Godzilla minus one has also made
it to the short list it'll be exciting
to see whether the iconic monster lizard
can ultimately beat its American
competitors who do you think deserves an
Academy Award this year we're looking
forward to your comments and of course
to the Academy's decision on March 10th
you can also find all the winners on
keno.com
we hope you enjoyed this week's news
which topics did you find most
interesting let us know in the comments
and if you haven't already done so take
a look at our big Disney episode where
we take a deep dive into all their
current issues and why Disney fans have
been disappointed if you're less into
Disney and more into horror and gaming
content check out our latest update for
Five Nights at Freddy's 2o thanks for
watching and we'll see you next
[Music]
time